I knew Jonathan went on to the optics
where look we're gonna learning
nonlinear optics at Harvard and then
from there went to IBM very first of all
the distinguished career at the
finishing his career John with managers
actually buzz became available then we
decided that we need some sort of
horrible agreement so IBM together and
John said whatever you do don't do that
all of the administrators out of it that
decide to take care of it gonna be by
very successful long-term collaboration
between my group and others here at IKEA
IBM going ministry the only sad thing
about that instability successful that
all the participants are not good
administration anyway so we're really
fortunate to have John
[Applause]
and you up or down as the case may be my
office which is 6-2 like many of you
here this afternoon or on making hard
about the changes in the climate for
research and development that have
occurred in our country changes that are
due
and the Cold War and the chain and
support of research by the military
changes due to the declining
competitiveness of some industries of
our country and changes due to the
deteriorating fiscal situation in our
country in a recent lecturer at UC Santa
Barbara about two years ago I dealt with
the issues raised or university of a
search by too great a rush to find that
deserve to industrial competitiveness
the lecture was entitled research and
problems of the new rationale that
lecture however did not address in depth
the issues which surround the definition
of an interaction now for the support of
basically surgeon and it's to those
questions that are proposed to turn
today some of what I have to say may be
disturbing but I want to the truth as I
have that I welcome discussion and that
I do not think for a minute that I have
the last word on these matters I have
been trying to think through a rationale
for society's support for basic research
without leaning on the emotionally
involved demand for us or the naive
analysis of impact that want to
sometimes hear from peers on the slack
side and without giving comfort to the
impatient and the activity that
sometimes characterized government
officials and corporate executives one
could hope to peruse the rationale for
basic research that is neither
excessively embossed nor excessively
modest in its claims the rationale which
can be used in Washington
or record groups as well as at the NSF
and in the faculty councils of our major
universities one could hope for a
rationale which does not distort the
complex history of science and
technology as they have actually
interacted over the last hundred and
fifty years such a rationality could be
found might be proof against the present
tendency to collect all the search
investments to the most immediate of
political and social concerns while at
the same time giving these concerns the
substantial link they deserve you will
think perhaps this is too grand a set of
intentions but I'm going to risk the
intent experience teaches us that it
pays to listen carefully to our pigs and
one of the credits we should be
listening to his representative Georgie
brown Jr who is one of the all-time best
supporters of Science and Technology and
who is the chairman of the committee on
Science Space and Technology of the US
House of Representatives in an article
called science it matters you have an
article in science 90 last October a
year ago article called rational science
irrational policy mr. Brown had many
falafels things to say about the
national mood respected public support
for basic resurgence in about the
behavior of both scientists and public
officials but in his on the topic of
basic research that I wish decloaking
this afternoon a more precise multi-drug
of the role of research in our culture
length portrayed applied research and
development as sources of the
technological innovation
fuel economic growth ease the struggle
for survival and three increasing
numbers of human beings to pursue
self-realization through endeavours of
the intellect and spirit such endeavors
he writes include the search for new
scientific knowledge through basic
research as well as the quest for
enlightenment through study and the
practice of religion philosophy is
between the artists particle
accelerators spacecraft cathedrals and
libraries are all essentially similar
they are settings for cultural
experience and the quote from
congressman Brown in other words the
congressman and he as you know is one of
our friends the congressman is saying
that basic research is a luxury of
individual self-realization that's
getting too expensive he is not saying
or he does not seem to be saying that
basic research is a necessity for modern
industrial societies thoughtful as I
find the article as a whole the comments
on basic research disturb all of us
in my view he characterizes basic
research by one of its minor attributes
namely the deep satisfaction sometimes
expressed by well-known scientists that
accompanied their work insights into
nation
furthermore the congressman's definition
is wise what stands out the distinction
between basic and applied research in my
experience first as a doer of research
and then as a director of a circuit
it was often harder to apply such sharp
distinctions constructively even to the
programs or to the work of individual
scientists it's a distinction which in
its sharpness confuses rather than
clarifies public understanding and
debate if we want to carry the day those
of us who believe but for those of us
who believe in basic researchers word
carry the day serious investments
historic earn our own hands on the use
of that term and motivations and our own
the very concept is under a cloud today
in many circles we need to dispel that
cloud if we are to the answer we also
need to clear away some semantic
underbrush from the term strategic
research but whether or not basic
research is a luxury and if not how much
of it our society can afford are two
different questions and we'll have to
keep both of mine as we proceed this
afternoon and I will try to deal with
both now one of the things George taught
me
was to put the most important things up
front so I'm going to summarize before I
give you the argument I'm going to
summarize it for you in a set of
intentionally oversimplified assertions
first technical sophistication is a
necessary but not sufficient condition
for a modern developed society to
achieve its goals second a vigorous set
of research institutions is a key
ingredient in many fields for helping
the society to achieve technical
sophistication third world leadership in
basic research is neither necessary nor
sufficient for the achievement of strong
economic growth and other national goals
at least over periods of many decades
just death just to solve that debt you
know what I'm thinking about how I'll
expand on that just a minute the u.s.
became the country with the highest rate
of productivity growth and the highest
absolute productivity in the world in
the latter half of the 19th century and
the 20th century long before we became
world leaders in business
Japan has done likewise with respective
productivity growth since World War two
without having yet become world class in
most areas of basically surgery there
are other examples but they show that
world leadership in basic research is
not necessary for society to achieve
important goals that it is not
sufficient it's almost too obvious to
require discussion but the example of
Great Britain after World War two or the
u.s. semiconductor industry in the 80s
or IBM in the recent past should suffice
to show the excellence in the search is
far from sufficient for the attainment
of national for the search but and this
is the main point world leadership and
basic research will constitute a
competitive advantage if but only if it
is coupled with world-class performance
in the much more extensive and diverse
set of skills institutions and
investments to come between important
assignment insights and the creation of
economic wealth and the rising standard
of whether that comparative advantage
from leadership and basic research is a
lot more substantial in man
well buried my field and with time but
overall it will be a comparative
advantage we would be foolish to forgo
in a world where the economic
competition is getting fiercer and
fiercer all the time
certain number five finally I will argue
that public support for the goal of
leadership and basic research and an
equal importance support for rational
strategy for reaching that goal will be
achievable if and only if there are
substantial changes and attitude leading
parts of the scientific community as
well as changes elsewhere in government
circles in Congress now I propose to
develop these propositions in more
detail but first I ask your indulgence
while I say a word about my view of
nature since I find on reflection that
the various definitions of the search of
what is fundamental or basic why it is
important all tend to derive from the
views held by the speaker about the
nature of nature 35 they say so and
since these are Salma Hayek's wasn't
they are often the cause of confusion my
part I persuaded that God did not make
the world according to the funding
categories of the National Science
Foundation or according to the
departmental structure
search universities or even according to
the priorities of the current Congress
and the newest version nature is not
divided up into compartments like the
wall post office boxes despite what you
might conclude from most course cabinets
proceed furthermore in my view nature is
inexhaustible or better said quoting
Freeman Dyson putting Emil weekers
nature is infinite in all directions
that nature is inexhaustible or infinite
in all directions leads to the
possibility of a special the
possibilities or an in scientific
discovery will be proportional to the
number of scientists working this of
course is behind the often pointed
factoid that to have more than a half
the science who ever lived are alive
today but the consequences of this
continuing and exponential growth
however are forcing themselves these
views have important bearing on the
analysis at least I claim they have
worth bearing on in Dallas
to get because nature is inexhaustible
it is highly unlikely they're all
results of basic research will be of
potential boundaries like saying all the
numbers between because the set of
unanswered questions is everywhere dense
we must constantly be on guard against
the idea and the people yes the second
one is unanswered questions is
everywhere dense above you but that is
not any justification for giving up in
our quest to understand nature or for
despairing of the utility for mankind of
much of what you do it does however tend
of different perspective the next thing
I want to do is give you my definition
of basically serve as background I could
but will not for lack of time describe
what I found by the listeners and
observation are the interesting set of
implicit not thought out definitions of
basic research used by many scientists
perhaps you'd like to return to that in
the discussion period but I choose to
define the basic research by what it is
not by what it is not moreover I choose
to place emphasis at least as much on
results as possible basic research in my
view this research that leads to new
understand that's the key word
understanding of how nature works how
things are ready connected and what are
the explanations applied research on the
other hand may usefully be defined as
research
something work this definition of
applied research office cocina helps us
to see how easily the line between basic
and Applied Research blurs since it is
an often useful strategy in making
something work to understand some some
aspect of nature's work and conversely
many scientists who achieve through
understanding in their basic research
are highly motivated to turn that
understanding into some new device some
new made thing and so definitely I do
not favor the term curiosity-driven and
as a synonym for basic research or even
as part of the typology of basic
research first in comparison paint and
air of frivolity - too many taxpayers of
congressmen but more importantly in my
view is not as near the mark as the
phrase understanding drew
now from this vantage point it's easy to
be clear in my view why basic research
is important to a country or to a
company why fact basic desert is not a
watching the importance of basic
research stairs first from the fact that
from time to time it discovers or
creates vast new possibilities for
achieving society's goals it is also a
battle because of much more frequently
the smaller understandings achieved
allow advances or improvements in
existing technologies of healthcare
productivity and the ninth treatment of
the environment of course having said
that we still have not yet dealt with
how much basic research society should
afford itself this human basic research
is much different than the view that is
that it is primarily a type of
self-realization or cultural activities
perhaps he's taken at face value the
claims of some parts of the physics
community to have an exclusive franchise
on fundamental research at Wayne which
all too often whatever is Barris is
allowed to blur into a claim to
exclusive franchise on basic research if
so we should open it now openly
acknowledge that the phrase basic
research has been stole and we should
insist on getting back now we also need
to add to the discussion that did
despite this notion that the defining
characteristic of basic research is new
insight into nature we should recognize
a society that was basic the search
primarily for the possibilities of
control and exploitation that it affords
that is sometimes of course that's a
company spawn supports research basic as
well most applied in the expectation and
the company uses this expectation of
competitive advantage along with his
insight into the future likely course of
its products and markets to choose
choose which areas that we serve are
perfectly new as a good best estimate
investments in a word as strategic
that's what a company expects for
research including the basic research
the nation expects better health effects
and a rising standard of living in an
environment
unnecessarily large or go through
research that can reasonably be expected
to contribute to these goals including
understanding through basic research is
what I am the National Science Board
special commission of the future of the
NSF mean and by strategic research
there's a lot more that needs to be said
about strategic research and I will
return to that minute but I'd like to
work make some other remarks that
perhaps put basic research further into
context as one of the several
methodologies by which start with new
discoveries may be made and new insights
obtain the other major weather by which
new insights are occasionally obtained
in fact I would say 30 or 40 percent of
the time is as an unexpected byproduct
of Applied decision in the course of
trying to make something work it
occasionally happens that questions are
implicitly put to nature which call for
unexpected and exciting in sense two of
the many possible examples are the
discovery of radio emission from the
heavens by Karl Jansky and the discovery
of the three degree Kelvin cosmic
background radiation by Wilson as I'm
sure you know both of these wonderful
discoveries were made in the course very
applied directed research a further
remark that helps put the discussion of
a basic
the context is even in areas where new
research can lead to new products
productivity to the achievement of
society's goals getting the R&D project
so to speak is not more than three to
five percent of the job
there's at least 20 or 30 times the
effort required in a whole complex of
other activities developed magnet energy
market development marketing finance
advertised price all which have to be
done
competitively that is quickly and well
if there is to be any lasting
competitive advantage to the company or
the nation which supported the research
in the first place we have a failure
that we share with the rest of our
fellow human beings which is that we
tend to overstate the importance of what
we do there are many cases where the new
insights from basic research are not one
thousandth of the job and we have not
only to understand the importance of
these other activities but also to give
them the degree of respect which is all
too rare for us to do what we do where
with the final analysis not really help
those whose tax dollar supports
unless these other tasks are done in a
world-class well in addition to
understand and respecting this there may
be other ways in which we science might
help and I will return to the subject in
life
lecture entitled where the science PhD
for by the way the observation that
getting the R&D right is only the small
part of the job is helpful in putting
this question in front of us how much
should be spent you know work how much
research is to immediate expulsion a
corporation should not over the long
term invest more in R&D that
successfully turned into added value for
as customers and share limitations in
the ability of the firm the non are
indeed originated limit what can be
capitalized on from R&D or it may be
that the marketplace is such that it is
no longer that it may once have done to
be able to your environment the support
guide for a company and I think for a
country it's to spend as much as you
could possibly afford better to make
sure or I will take that say it is just
to make sure that the under ninety-five
percent of the job is in good hands and
under control and this is worried about
at this point further increases in R&D
now I'm going to come back to the notion
of strategic reserves which is in great
need of clarification it is not a
category which is a primary right
category to the support of the city
recall its strategic research as
research in scientific areas which are
good bets to be helpful in reaching the
agreed upon goals whether the country or
the corporation it's the task of those
who support research in rivers with the
idea of achieving goals to support the
complete spectrum of research from the
most basic through engineering and
applied research in those areas perhaps
a bit of history will help once at the
university based research establishment
of which we are so proud of in that
which we are so worried was created and
sustained over the last 40 years was
created as a strategic investment in
superior military systems that's not
true evolve it that's too emotional it
was certainly true for the Renaissance
of modern optical physics by the way as
Professor Charles Terence of UC Berkeley
has pointed out that many occasions his
early work on liquid spectroscopy was
not part of a program of strategic
research it was part of what one might
call discipline totally driven basic
research but once these microwave laser
had been invented and demonstrated even
though at that point quantum electronics
was still really in its infancy it was
clear to the sponsors that they should
have increased their support for basic
research in quantum electronics because
it had become a very good that indeed
that there would be applications of real
value
it had become strategic for surgery
almost the word go the motivation of the
researchers did not change of it they
were still motivated by the desire to
understand but what they did was in a
different class as seen by the sponsors
so willing professor Biko Bloomberg
explanatory work in know in nonlinear
optics which I had enjoyed to be
associated was no less pioneering for
having been part of the strategic
research of the joint services
electronic from now I'm gonna forget the
one of the annual reviews when the joint
services electronic commander came to
Cambridge to review this and he come up
and introduced the proceedings by saying
there are three types of intelligence
[Music]
but those who supported him in other
skatin see that there was a high
likelihood that many useful things would
come out of this exciting and expanding
they backed those punches with support
for strategic basic research these
examples want to make clear that there
is no inherent conflict between
strategic research and done by
individuals understand nation this is
not summation by the way over time
directly as much at the funding agencies
and Congress as at the signs of the
community moreover since critique
research includes the entire spectrum
from basic to applied there should be no
reason to talk as if the standards of
peer review or quality expected or the
participation of top researchers will
somehow be less in strategic areas and
discipline only driven areas now that we
can that those of us who advocate the
use of the category such as a teacher
for surgery are well aware of the
reluctance of many in the scientific
community to embrace this note today
we're also aware of the real
difficulties to be faced it wouldn't
takes this category seriously and tries
to use it to shape debate and policy I
propose the deal with the theater first
and a difficulty center so far as I can
tell the fears are of two comments first
that the category of strategic research
includes the teaching basic research
will lead to disproportionate funding
for such work to the detriment of what
I've been calling discipline only ruin
isn't second there is the fear that
misunderstanding of the complex
interplay between basic and applied
research will lead in the strategic
areas to the requirement that even the
basic research be done of the work
according to me
during timetables and lastly those of
you who follow the recent discussion of
the Senate Appropriations Committee
report on the NSF will appreciate that
there is a real theory we despite this
notion on the grounds that it doesn't
work and it doesn't work because it
doesn't reflect the way in which nature
gives up receivers as I said the dangers
are real but it may help us as a nation
to avoid them and still make proper use
of the notion of strategic research if
we reflect on some of the important
differences between basic research in
era strategic for military systems and
the support basic research and areas
thought to be many positions were
discussed at length of effort in that
earlier a lecture than I mentioned the
role of the government these of the
research and support the military
systems was and is very different than
the possible roles of government as a
supporter of research in aid of
competitiveness or other civilians the
government is the customer for military
systems and as such can guide and
control and support of research by
whether it's clearly understood needs
are being met or are elected but the
government is not now and never will be
the definitive customer for most of the
civilian economy this really changes
matters it is not expert on the results
to be expected moreover at least for 25
of those 50 golden past years the
military did not have to conduct the
bulk of its support or its reasoning
about the search support under the
public
parenthetically the fact that the
strategic motors of the military service
and basic reserves were not subject to
constant debate as had the unintended
consequence that several generations of
physical sciences we're trained and have
done much of their work without ever
having had to think about why they were
so that of course has changed
dramatically in the last two or three
years another key point from that
earlier electric is to point out the
deficiencies in u.s. industrial
competitiveness have almost nothing to
do with lack of speedy technology
transfer from university labs or
government lack of competitiveness stems
from failures of investment lack of
attention to low-cost manufacturing lack
of attention to training too many other
factors which are failures of corporate
management or failures of macroeconomics
or both these will not be cured by
better technology transfer by the way
the overwhelmed as a longtime user of
the product of the University the
overwhelmingly most effective load of
technology transfer from the
universities to the civilian economy
despite the trained students which you
send out by the way unless we turn them
out with two years Pegasus what they
never work further drives a nail in the
coffin of any hope
every kind of job would warn them so
there are these important differences in
how the government was approached the
teachers research for the civilian
economy compared to what worked so well
during the Cold War for Strategic
Research and supportable criticism and
part of the distress that we all feel
about is due in part to the fact that
the consequences of these differences
have not really been digested in the way
either that the scientific community
approaches the new strategic research or
in the way that the funding agencies and
economists the other major fear caused
by the phrase strategic research is that
it will lead to the withdrawal of
funding from areas of research not
described as strategic there's a real
danger here as well but you can be
confronted and I believe manage so the
argument is solved that we'll need a
great deal of explanation illustration
and repetition as I've already said I
believe that it is possible to pick out
areas of basic research which are the
glue that in a healthy society to
achieve its goals say the environmental
remediation in many other areas money
does not follow it because we can pick
areas which are glued bets we know what
areas of science are not we may be able
to conclude in fact I had conclude that
certain areas are very long shots indeed
but it is the height of arrogance and
followed to make that decision of that
wall of the so-called
known strategic errors were we to do so
we would be voluntarily and perversely
cutting ourselves off from likely
sources of assistance a further reason
why it is proved to keep many of the
discipline only driven field telling and
vigorous
the whole and in particular to the
health of the so-called strategic
parents including the basic assertion on
Ceres
this is another consequence of the fact
that nature is not in fact very well
described by the categories of our
conventional scientific disciplines
however this argument that I expected at
all automate this argument would be much
stronger if these scientists had a
culture which was more encouraging but
the main reason for vigorous support of
the non strategic areas is that we
cannot know perhaps this point is not
well understood by those who say we're
normal but this brings us squarely up
the high jump
I hope with the feeders want to deal
with the other issues here with
difficulties of the notion of strategic
research since nature is an exhausted
and the number of fields and subfields
and his specialization seems to be
nearly limitless how can they rationally
decide how much money should be spent
and on waking deeds here the sociology
and cultural science are little healthy
and it is here we may have to make some
changes in expectations by definition we
cannot use the criterion understood
utility we do not have a methodology by
which the scientific community can come
to anything like the consensus in
recommendations for those who make a
public policy severely compromises our
ability to say convincing way to those
of the cause that basic research is a
necessary part of the achievement of our
national goals even in areas outside the
strategic areas as you will be aware
some of our colleagues give a simple
answer support of all fields to the
extent that their members will feel
themselves well character I hope you
agree that this is not now the National
Academy of Sciences the National Academy
of Engineering in the Institute of
Medicine have recently issued a report
from their Committee on science
engineering and public policy which
begins to deal with these difficulties
it is called science technology in the
national goals it recommends that would
be a u.s. national goal to be among the
leaders in all major fields of science
and the clearly outstanding leader and
what I've been referred to as deep
errors in their language we should be
the cleaner world leaders in those areas
of science which may lead to believe the
expected to contribute to that amount of
growth healthcare national security and
Environmental Protection
the report goes on to recommend the
process of comparative international
assessment to determine who is in the
lead in all major fields along with an
analysis of what is required to achieve
or maintain the lead in areas deep
crucial to national goals
the word also suggests that these
comparative assessments would turn up
fields of science in which the
over from the presumably the results of
the assessments would be to the
following type to the supporters of
research what we would say for example
our performance name feel they is not
about the first rank but it needs to be
to help achieve our national goals so
its funding must be sharply increase our
performance in field B is world-class
but that is an area which is not among
the areas in which we desire to be world
leaders we will be satisfied to be among
the leaders and therefore one assessment
I don't think I will ever live to read
is the assessment consensus where as
good or better in this field as we need
to be and any extra money if there is
some sort of go to other views
however such an assessment would be
irrational an outcome of this process in
mind however my doubt the ability of the
current culture of science to support
such a rational undertaking at least as
long as it involves decisions to reduce
funding some errors but the scientific
enterprise in the United States is so
large in absolute terms and so
successful in most of its parts that the
inevitable result of most assessments
will be that we are among the world
leaders and since we have the world's
largest economy it is appropriate that
we be among the world leaders of most
areas so we will have a teeny part of
these new maximal goals assessments will
be required however make sure we do not
slip the crucial what would be a
convincing step for the scientific
establishment to take and which would
help counteract the view that we are
just one more speculative special
leaders who perhaps not especially
losers would be to find ways to agree on
the fields which are studied which I
don't think and then we will have to
find ways to agree upon that discipline
only driven fields which should be
supported keeping in mind that some
fields will generate generate insight
and training them Sciences much more
economically no trees to do this we will
have to give up the view held by many
the basic research is all of a piece
that distinctions
should not be drawn and that one should
spend whatever it takes to exploit all
of the good scientific opportunities
this is a serious and important agenda
in public policy an omission in the
goals for a new report that I've been
discussing in my view is any discussion
yet who an authority should call for
these assessments and who will only
results in the sense of expecting to
tackle but I believe it's a worthy
direction for the nation it pursued and
if successful it will allow us to answer
with conviction leadership and basic
research is knowledge it is a potential
comparative advantage for the country
that at the same time does a world-class
job at all the other processes by which
new insight is turned into society bound
moreover we would have a rational way of
allocating support for basic research
not only the strategic fields also in
the other areas of discipline driven
science whose health and from which
experience has talks they come
unexpected contributions your attention
and I will be glad to respond
I believe that the government has to be
very careful about intervening in a
major way in the civilian economy which
your first example the example of
cemetery which some of you will be
familiar with is my idea of how they're
going to do this basically like that you
know it's hard it'll be hard to get away
two or three more times but basically
what happened was the industry got
together and said we need to work
together first of all and we need
government support in improving
manufacturing technology for
semiconductors we don't put up half the
money we would like
and by the way we in private industries
will entirely determine the research
program if if the I don't think that's
when you characterize the fuel-efficient
cars are already timetable sunglasses so
this is an example of what I say the
market maker it's difficult for it to
know about first of all this is not the
field in which I'm an expert I hear we
have gotten ourselves into a situation
where we're damned if we do and then to
push it through at this point it is
going to cause very very arm to the
cause of science that I've been
discussing here generally for it to
disappear in flames we'll have another
sewer a very bad effect I think of a
second it was falling in my view to make
this my National what the national
interest is there then don't have gotten
in the first people second credentials
when there is no conceivable national
interest as opposed to this manatee
apologist energy complex with respect to
science it's a it's hard to believe that
all that knowledge won't be Danvers
whether there are alternative ways to
live but eating your description of the
National Academy of Sciences report it
sounded as if you're advocating the
funneling of funding to Ireland to
mediocracy partner it sounds as if
you're advocating the funding of the
funding to islands of mediocrity and
that the words you make your area look
the more money you'll get and who
exactly which people which individuals
again you see less complicit in your
welcome
that's for this way it is implicit that
they say in areas that are important to
the nation if we are not doing well be
sure to characterize that and I would
not suggest that it is wise
first of all I don't believe there are
any areas that will be found to be
strategic to in a sense that I spent so
much time following them in which they
are down the public's paying for and if
there are areas of science that can
reasonably help us achieve our goals and
for whatever reason disinterest disdain
or under investment we have not been
working there we should I'm sorry but
who will the money goes to if they want
to go to the best damned then in order
be allocated in the same way
and that will achieve an improvement if
you believe in peer review or not mine
quite frankly my observation this is
meant as a friendly comment is that if
you establish the budget they will call
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's one night at some length in earlier
paper called research and
competitiveness that is one of the
problems of the new rationale I when I
said in the paper was when it was a
question of military systems of better
cruise business it was okay the most of
my Fedora MIT and Caltech and Johns
Hopkins but it is economic
competitiveness that is the main driver
then no region of the US will think it
has less planeman and go I think that is
a very serious word and the fact that
we're going to have declining amounts of
money to spread around in the face of
these forces is some that makes it makes
it worse but quite frankly that is a
that's a problem that we have to solve
apart from this other issue well are we
working where we want to be work and
it's often easy for us here at MIT or at
Harvard
one day I go to the best places and we
are chopping off the fingers of the
congressman who supports I'm to the port
it's another thing to carry that day and
part of the problem I think is that
because we do not yet deal adequately
with some of these issues that I raised
today we are perceived as special
leaders and therefore were in the top
tempted to say come to my third science
PhD because that's part that is I think
part of the answer many of you know that
better than it's one of the time to
address here today was ambitious enough
they're trying to say within the family
so to speak one of the things that we
ought to be sort of reassessment
thinking about what it will take to
improve the scientific literacy in a
dramatic way you know as well
yes sir that's a very poor point in this
logical argument and I was rushing
towards the end but I did in fact in my
text have something to say for that that
is remember I said that one of the
omissions in the report from the
National Academies was they did not say
who would call four-and-oh as well as
who would do this process now it can be
done that is the whole premise of the
Industrial Research is that it is
possible to pick out the set of
scientific areas in which there's a good
bet that you will get paid so when it
comes to the set of high-tech industries
or improving healthcare or environmental
remediation it is not a major job to
figure out what areas are reasonably
included in strategic by the way it's
most of science below 10 to the 8 or 10
to the nine TV
but but the more detailed assessments I
think are not hard to make real question
is who will call for work and who will
use well the issue is who will pay for
the research part of I mean the federal
government now pays for a whole lot of
search it is reasonable to assume that
they would continue to pay for research
as it applies to national goals as well
as it applies to the health of science
generally there is not a mechanism to
cost this analysis to take place in the
moment that is a whole but it's a it's a
whole not only of my exposition but it's
a whole in fact I couldn't cover it up
Ashville classic records about the role
of universities versus national we have
tremendous lots of people currently
without the balance of support for
students and sends the now many graduate
students
Church have their support come from
Grants and contracts that are controlled
by
versus balances right it seems to
balance if we place the money in the
hands of students disputing the
resources geographically that doesn't
that bring them mark I think that's and
I think it's I think it is not only
right but I think it's Council I say
this as a guest in the common and it's
particularly courageous point to make at
MIT where you know within a microsecond
after enrolling as a graduate students
what is captured by a research by the
search program but I think that is that
if they ask them as the presidential
investigator programs do that I think
the National Science Foundation
functions used to do if they are in the
hands of the students and are not high
so possible you know in most cases to to
research produce I could never have a
very selling to one of the one of the
things that is missing in all of this to
give you just a foretaste of the third
lecture the the interaction during
graduate years between the between
students in the university and their
professors in
diversity and the places where science
is done in the outside world that
interaction is in need of a great little
strengthen and the having more money of
the speletons as opposed to grants like
facilitate new mechanisms to do that as
well it really is it really is
fundamental
it doesn't exhaust basic research but it
certainly is I think I think the
probabilities of any sort of effective
spin-off at these extreme energies are
revoked but if shared widely enough and
if done on a if shared by Molina I think
it is a reasonable goal for some of our
room a search I just as I say like
there's no no reason to make that a
matter of national pride words but I
don't think that's equivalent to saying
that we shouldn't we should turn away we
just got ourselves a new way we've
gotten ourselves into
[Music]
for example 25 years old black by
ultimate document considers research
ever left I can see the head of
Massachusetts economy I'm afraid that a
more cynical way to my teacher research
see to search the course box to
iterative improvements on existing
technologies and I think that's not the
best inclined in the long run and in
fact basic probability of generators and
technology are actually more likely
become relatively undirected basic
search by category from use the words by
well I should say the side
well I understand the issue and I got
weather like in my remarks and I guess
what you're saying is that you don't
believe in our ability to successfully
manage that distinction and you may be
right but what I the point of one of the
points of my lectures was that if we
have no conviction about this or don't
understand this it's holes or the world
of law so I don't think we have a trucks
and to say well is this danger and there
is a distinctive and not say my god I
can do just this basic research of a
strategic area somewhere else and my god
the health of the whole depends for the
reasons that you know that I said on the
health of these other areas if we can't
speak with enthusiasm and conviction
about this now we're in a very serious
long-term trouble so I I would say you
know we've got to lead on all the
whistle in the dark a little bit more
and get our convictions
you